ben affleck you may have heard of this
guy apparently he's some kind of
hollywood actor people are very excited
that he's going to be the next Batman he
has been a big fundraiser politically
especially for the Democrats but he did
an interview in Playboy magazine and it
sounds like he's soured on the money in
politics over time I became
disillusioned mostly with the pernicious
effect of money in politics I realized
it was about raising 56,000 through a
couple dinners and those bundlers who
bring in 1 million or 2 million those
people are dedicated me and they believe
in what they're doing I believe in why
many of them are doing it what I don't
believe in is that we now have the need
to do it and for me personally it
started to feel gross okay I'm pretty
sure we can all get on board that it's
something we talked about here
especially at the Young Turks all the
time money in politics and it's a real
problem if you've lost Hollywood with
money is that is this exhibition great
well I don't say this is a game changer
if you've lost a guy like Ben Affleck
was raised that I mean he's pretty much
one of the most outspoken uh celebrities
they have if you lost him is this really
kind of see change kind of impressed
that he knows the word pernicious that's
kind of cool ideas my pronunciation
pernicious in any census really I'm
gonna have to up my game yeah but um you
know it's it's it's interesting that
finally somebody like him that is very
vocal speaks out about it now because it
is disgusting and gross across all
spectrums I think politics has gotten to
that point where you know people say
Obama's back on the plane he's almost
out of office and he's still fundraising
but it is kind of a gross sort of slimy
feeling when you know Obama's come into
Hollywood just a fundraise just to go to
a house and go home with five million
dollars it's kind of like you know sly
little making traffic terrible in west
LA young people hate it and he literally
did that two weeks ago really he'll get
a private fundraiser and it's something
like 50 I mean you know it's bad if you
want to take a shower after you have
dinner at these people because you feel
so slightly feel slimy what do you make
of this kind of thing because I think
there's something interesting about Ben
Affleck and Matt Damon because you know
Matt Damon's been a big proponent of
of public schools but also sends his kid
to private school so there's something
like as these guys grow up they're
learning the system is seriously broken
I don't blend that they are I mean it's
been it's taken a while I guess for some
of this to dawn on some of the Hollywood
folks about how actually wrong it is
that our month at our politics is so
infused with money at every stage of the
game you know I think that that would be
wonderful to get money out but in order
to get money out of our system you have
to elect people who will then be able to
vote to get money out and so limits you
know there are differences about term
limits there are some problems that I
have with it you know it tends to
perpetuate the party boss system because
people don't get experience and they
cannot stay in office long enough and I
have that conversation I said for four
years from people in chronic my husband
goes you know let them have eight they
need they need time to do something
about then get it out so he would write
exactly one election so you get one
cycle of eight years and you can't run
for real actually because then people do
I think a lot of people get into
politics wanting to make a difference
people are engaged and they are like I
can do something for my community and
they're engaged about it but then all of
a sudden they realize they get in I
think maybe Obama might be the same way
you get in you think oh I'm gonna do
these things I'm gonna be present and
then you realize it's the same the cog
and we you know it just it nothing
really changes and it's all about money
and it's all about you know oval if I
want this past and I have to do this in
this pneus and it's kind of just it
isn't the ideal situation everybody
thinks it's gonna be when they get in
and then money is corrupt it's like
Frodo and the ring you're like oh I
gotta keep our term limits or you know
that doesn't actually get money out I
mean what you need to do is you have to
be able to elect those people who will
then promise and actually follow through
on voting to get these changes made it
is done where are those people because
we usually exist but they can't rise
above the din of the money you know
there are folks who are running in
congressional districts and in school
board races all around but because money
is so deeply infused I mean even with
term limits I don't see how that goes at
alum it's at least it's a step in the
right direction that people can you
realize that they're not just going to
sit there and you know a year before a
reelection they're just going to pander
to whoever is going to
give them the most money and then they
just keep doing the same things even
though they promised to do something out
don't you guys wonder like when they're
supposed to be working you know to me
like if you think about it Obama ran for
reelection that whole last year of his
first term was devoted to getting
reelected he was real ending the show I
always wonder that right you're supposed
to have an aww I think as a politician
or suppose have a job but yet half your
term ends up becoming about reelection
even now he's raising money he's not
running for reelection obviously but
he's still raising money for the DNC so
it just sort of never the creators in
the asylum were running okay but
seriously why don't we ever talk about
campaign finance anywhere we used to
have something mccain-feingold I mean
there was things that were trying to
change but literally it's not part of
the national discussion at all oh I
think it's just because it's been taken
over so completely when you have the
oligarchy that we have right now and I
you know I don't think anybody will
disagree with me really on that but when
you have that kind of that that level of
oligarchy and money and politics they've
really infiltrated at all levels you
know we have the Alec the American
Legislative Exchange Council doing the
template legislation then it's been put
through out Republican legislators
throughout the country that have helped
to cement this corporate control and
this this sort of the billionaire's
influencing pretty much everything that
actually can get done because they have
the money and then you have something
like Tom Steyer the hedge fund
billionaire who's now decided to step in
because he realizes climate change is in
deeply important issue and so he's
putting his money to work Michael
Bloomberg putting his money to work we
got Bloomberg and we've got steyr we've
got billionaire action on a their
billionaire on billionaire action right
is what we're working on and I don't
know if that's actually going to work if
they're gonna be able to get those
people elected and over that hump of
campaign financing to get to the
congressional election so that they can
vote for analytics and politicians are
all about money whether you're democrat
republican libertarian nothing Green
Party whatever it's all money and
they're all the same I mean people talk
about Democrat Republicans and really
when you look at eight on the broad
spectrum sure maybe you're like okay
there's differences between the two
really when you look at it with
microscope there's really no difference
they're all about money they all are
rich they're hauler you know well that
also is proven all the time when you see
who they get who Wall Street gives money
to it's not that they give eighty
percent to Republican
and twenty percent of Democrats it's
always around 49 and 51 percent because
they're playing both sides constant all
right i'll have you know it's toxin on a
wall street i mean you know so it's not
like the the democrats over there going
oh no we have no money invested in the
stock market we have no vested interest
in Wall Street come on they all do I
actually know some individuals who are
just regular people who decided that
they got in to try get regular people
under that's what I mean you know
medical middle-class folks who are not
wealthy who are not folks who are
billionaires or even millionaires or
even thousand heirs and I have tried to
run for Congress and the barriers to
entry are very high part of that is set
by your state legislature you have to
have ten thousand dollars just to file
in some of these states or more and with
those kinds of barriers to entry for a
regular person to then be able to rise
above the din of the money that is
influenced are there that they have so
surprising to me they're not all the
same I mean I know people I know are
physical individuals who have tried to
do this and it's extremely difficult so
maybe the ones that rise up ultimately
become all the same but at the
grassroots level there are its level the
people that we would need to get elected
and in place in order to put the judges
in place who say corporations are not
people in order to get you know the
constitutional amendments those all all
spin on the House of Representatives
yeah okay so final thought on this which
you just gave me a perfect segue for is
how much it is should we blame on the
Supreme Court and the Citizens United
ruling because corporations can now give
they oh they had back-channel ways to do
it but now we've completely opened it up
and so should we be blaming the Supreme
Court for this situation that we're now
I blame everybody yeah you know what I
mean government obviously there's a we
need government for democracy and to
make the laws and the rules and stuff
like that and it's so there's so many
rules and things that we have to follow
and do that it just you almost wish you
could start over and just start with a
clean template and say this is what we
need to do and you don't have to do a
million things to do this or you know it
just I don't know I think it's we need
the Supreme Court and rulings like that
you kind of shake your head and go hmm
really now you're going to make it easy
for corporations to do these things that
they were hiding to do before I don't
know I'm you know we're home desi
the Supreme Court is the fulcrum you
know it is the pivot on which everything
is going to turn and you know there's
sort of the the last ditch below the
wall the guardrail if you want to use
another metaphor that keeps us from
sliding completely into complete
takeover with a corporation this is yeah
but so so that's that's I think where
the crux of it lies because these people
you know have a lifetime appointment so
it really does matter who's in the
Senate to approve the person who is the
person in the presidential office to
nominate the people that we're going to
see and we see the fruits of you know
Scalia and Alito and Thomas it just it
leaves us in a place where we are
extremely vulnerable to the kinds of
overtaking the kinds of systems that
that overtake us that make us in a very
really day limits to make all night baby
do that that's a whole that's a whole
other topic which will deal with maybe
next week we'll see